bonjour bruno dachicourt merci de
répondre à nos questions ce matin sur
arte france qu'est ce que vous attendez
de cette journée de perturbations
cette jeune perturbations c'est un coup
de semonce parce que contrairement à la
déception des britanniques ont pour
obtenir les mêmes propos parce que le
brut tic a été l'accord comme une
opération commerciale et et signer il ya
quasiment un an et depuis 11 mois nous
attendons toujours
de faire tout simplement respecté à
appliquer l'accord et ce sont les
britanniques y de
joue la montre rajoute des clauses qui
n'étaient pas inclus dans l'accord et
aujourd'hui on fait ces actions pour
rappeler
aux britanniques et aux gouvernements
britannique que nous sommes toujours là
et que nous sommes toujours mobilisés
c'est à dire quoi c'est une capacité de
nuisance vis-à-vis de londres vous êtes
prêts à aller jusqu'au pour vous faire
entendre pour obtenir gain de cause
on rappelle un vous ne bloquer que
quelques heures ces différents sites
aujourd'hui mais si vous n'obtenez pas
gain de cause de blocage peut durer
quels moyens de pression vous allez pour
vous faire entendre encore à l'avenir
mais voilà c'est pour montrer que
contrairement à ce que l'on pourrait
croire c'est pas insignifiant lesquels
soi-disant quelques licences qui manque
c'est c'est quand même 150 entreprises
autant de familles derrière voire plus
et tout derrière toute une filière qui
pourrait en pâtir
on a été plutôt dans la concertation et
chiens rappeler que c'est juste là le
respect de l'accord dans le respect de
l'accord c'est quoi c'est que il y avait
un accès pour les britanniques au marché
européen est une des contreparties c'est
que les navires européens eux avaient
accès aux eaux anglaises toutes les
zones où empêcher voilà donc cesser on
ne demande pas plus que ce que l'accord
prévoyait vous venez de parler en 550
fameuse licence supplémentaire qu'elle
demande paris paris qu'on a obtenu 960
donc c'est un peu près 80% qui manquent
quelles seront les conséquences
justement pour les pêcheurs français qui
sont concernés on se souvient la
ministre de la mère annick girardin a
avait évoqué il ya une semaine un plan
de sortie de flotte pour les bateaux
restant à quai ça avait d'ailleurs fait
réagir beaucoup de pêcheurs qui ont
évoqué un naufrage de la france et
l'union européenne face à la grande
bretagne
oui les conséquences hors jeu pas
revenir sur twitter youtube parce que
c'est qu'un outil parmi eux parmi le
plan de
l'ajustement pour le holy à l'accord il
ya des plans il ya des fonds pour les
plans de modernisation de
diversification et parmi ceux-là aussi à
ceux malheureusement pour les
entreprises qui n'auraient d'autre choix
sur le volontariat d'y aller mais nous
c'est surtout que derrière ils voient
des conséquences de report de flottis et
quelque part ça serait aussi
ça pourrait être remise en cause de la
politique commune des pêches et donc
c'est pour ça aussi que cette action là
c'est pour rappeler à l'europe 2 qu'elle
doit continuer à défendre les intérêts
des pêcheurs européens
et voilà aujourd'hui des pêcheurs
français dans cet accord et
voilà on veut que ça aille vite parce
que le 31 décembre c'est pas très loin
et que nous il faut des réponses bien
avant sa part du 31 décembre et 10
décembre est également la commission
européenne a demandé au royaume uni de
régler les litiges avec la france autour
des licences donc avant le 10 décembre
est ce que aujourd'hui pour vous un
accord semble possible avant cette date
quelles sont les marges de manoeuvre
pour négocier
mais
c'est mon seul sinon plus grand souhait
c'est que effectivement au 10 décembre
on ait trouvé des accords sur la
méthodologie de des navires remplaçant
parce que là on fait un focus sur sur
les licences mais il n'ya pas que ça
c'est à dire que vu comment ça s'est
passé pour les licences on est en droit
de se demander comment ça va se passer
pour les mesures techniques qui arrivent
pour les stocks partagés pour les
espèces non soumises à quotas
les pieds au derrière il ya aussi les la
question des aires marines protégées
anglaise donc tous à
la résolution des problèmes des licences
des
ouvres des anglais
montrent que
je veux dire la maison n'est pas bonne
parce que du coup ça ça vous monte nos
inquiétudes pour le premier négociations
pour la suite pour tous les autres
sujets qui a derrière je parle des
navires en passant parce que c'est
important aujourd'hui mais à l'avenir si
on veut changer à remplacer à navire il
faut bien avoir les conditions dans
lesquelles ça doit toucher et
aujourd'hui on n'a pas de réponse parce
qu'ils passent que les parce que les
anglais nous voilà imposent leurs choix
qui n'était pas dans l'accord et donc il
faut que la commission européenne reste
ferme et
défendre nos positions vous avez
confiance en la commission européenne
ont parlé tout à l'heure de la déception
les britanniques ont dit qu'ils étaient
déçus par votre action du jour donc
londres a réagi mais est ce que
bruxelles a réagi par rapport à votre
action est ce que vous avez un retour
également du gouvernement français vous
êtes soutenus dans cette journée
d'action
non mais le soutien du gouvernement
français a toujours depuis le départ
après comme c'est un accord de
coopération entre le royaume uni et
l'europe effectivement c'est bien
l'europe qui négocient je pense que
malheureusement la pluie trop
tardivement la
la mesure de
la mesure des enjeux c'est que
aujourd'hui les voilà
non je pense qu'ils s'étaient pas rendu
compte de l'impact ça pouvait avoir sur
des régions comme la bretagne la
normandie où la france ça va
effectivement il ya d'autres enjeux dans
l'accord de coopération commerciale avec
les anglais et la pêche comme on l'avait
signalé notre inquiétude c'est une
variable d'ajustement et aujourd'hui
c'est le cas et maintenant on espère que
l'europe veut dire que la mesure est que
elle va faire tout pour obtenir
l'application de l'accord c'est tout ce
qu'on demande on ne demande rien de plus
que ce qui a été négocié
merci bruno dachicourt d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
membre d'un syndicat des marins pêcheurs
cftc